Abby's waffle Toy Story
Andy's mom was responsible for two kids
a dog and a bunch of talking toys so
that's like sexy this looks like a lot
of girls that I know that I've seen with
Hollywood she's a little playing on a
MILF scale I put her at like a 3 or 4 I
would love to see her when she was like
23 college age toys 3 mom oh my god I
don't want to do any dirty things to her
they made her too hot it'd be weird I
don't care about buzzing woody I just
want to see Andy's mom swimming but she
seems like a wonderful lady but no I
don't want to her if that's what you
mean the Evil Queen that's really
original yeah getting away house she's
got the sexy eyes she looked Italian
she'd be a devil in the face oh my god
but just that look she's giving me right
now I mean it's just like she's clearly
on some things if she's like not messed
up like on drugs or whatever I think
it's a yes I would eat the apple off of
her wherever she was placing and I don't
even like apples she can get it before
she even knew she was a superhero
absolutely yes absolutely you're kidding
bone the hips to buy them oh yeah she
kinda had a sexy voice she's loud and
abrasive and confident I'm into all that
stuff and imagine the crazy things she
can do
in the bedroom put the uniform on maybe
cut some holes in a few places oh man I
forgot my cell phone upstairs and she's
like don't worry babe if I was like into
like a mixture between pottery and
elephant
maybe gun to your head you had to mrs.
Potts
okay mm-hmm how would you put her
through the lid lukewarm tea you know
I'm done with the big brown thing in the
back so you know I could be done with a
teacup booty
Oh mr. potty oh you need to get out I'm
a maybe she's got to be hot she's a
teapot she's always hot oh come on let
us not speak ill of the dead this is the
animal I gotta say this is the first
time in my life that I've thought about
[ __ ] Bambi's mom if we were deer yes
I have a feeling she's kind of a dead
fish in bed look all your thumper you
know what at this point of my life why
not I'm gonna pass on this one it's an
animal yeah I'm glad she's dead no way
you don't think that dogs hot got a lot
of kids so I'm kind of scared about that
yeah personally I don't think I was ever
into a Haida lady yeah she thought she
was better than me
I mean no one lady and you're crazy
she'd win in a dog show
oh this is where I can't might draw the
line even with the lights off that's a
gorilla here we're down for the deer you
were down for the dog but you stopped at
a gorilla not in this situation the
gorilla would crushed me in any well
that's why you get on top of her this is
a big no for me
ha no
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I think it's safe to say whipped up